unsere heutige welt ist schnelllebig und
chaotisch geprägt von fortschritt
technologie und kommunikation uns
beschäftigen probleme die alltäglichen
und internationalen unsere welt
verändert sich heute jeden tag immer
schneller
wir forschen mehr wir kommunizieren mehr
es gibt heute mehr menschen auf der welt
als jemals zuvor in der geschichte der
menschheit
du kennst diese welt aber schnell die
für einen augenblick vor du verlässt
diesen planeten
stell dir vor du fällst heute ins koma
und öffnet erst in zehn jahren das
nächste mal die augen
wie sieht die welt aus was hat sich
geändert
wie ist das jahr 2026 wie stark hat sich
der alltag deiner freunde und deiner
familie geändert wie sehen die städte
aus welche wendungen hat es in der
politik gegeben welche probleme haben
wir vielleicht gelöst und welche
probleme sind in zehn jahren aktuell
welchen fortschritt hat die technologie
gemacht
die frage die dahinter steht ist siehst
du die jetzige welt positiv oder negativ
wachsen uns probleme wie erderwärmung
energieverbrauch flüchtlingskrise oder
überbevölkerung langsam aber sicher über
den kopf oder steuern wir getrieben
durch technischen fortschritt auf ein
goldenes zeitalter zu oder wird sich im
vergleich zu heute nicht allzu viel
verändert haben
wir werden ein paar probleme gelöst
haben und dafür sind wieder ein paar
neue aufgetaucht der alltagstrott zu vor
sich hin wie er es immer getan hat
nur dass das smartphone eben etwas
smarter wird und sich unser auto
inzwischen mit dem toaster unterhalten
kann
als ich auf facebook und twitter gefragt
habe wie ihr die zukunft sieht habe ich
ausschließlich negativer
zukunftsprognosen gelesen und das
bereitet mir ehrlich gesagt sorgen
vielleicht noch mehr als unsere
temporären probleme denn unsere
einstellung dem leben gegenüber bestimmt
auch unser handeln
was wird aus einer politikverdrossenen
gesellschaft die angst vor der zukunft
hat
die zukunft ist heute undurchsichtiger
als jemals zuvor
es ist schwierig sich etwas vorzustellen
dass unseren alltag so sehr verändern
wird wie das internet aber das nächste
große ding ist bis jetzt immer gekommen
eine stromversorgung für jeden haushalt
ein auto zum privaten transport ein
telefon für die private kommunikation
vielleicht ist es künstliche intelligenz
vielleicht ist es virtual reality
vielleicht ist es etwas das noch nie
jemand erdacht hat niemand kann zehn
jahre in die zukunft sehen
aber genau deswegen ist es meiner
meinung nach umso wichtiger einen
positiven ausblick zu haben
einmal zu träumen unsere vorstellung der
zukunft beeinflusst auch für diese
zukunft wirklich aussehen wird wir
träumen vom mars wir fliegen zum mars
wir träumen von einer virtuellen
realität wir bauen uns ein
also träumt
wie sieht die zukunft aus